as I mentioned an election season is in
full swing I think there are currently
850 Republican candidates running it's
gonna get worse - yeah there's a there's
a hunt new hundred every hour but you
know it doesn't seem like someone new
announces they're running for president
about every 30 seconds well today Mike
Huckabee entered the race and three
other people declared their candidacies
in just the past four days they're
stacking up well the 2016 presidential
election is already such a big story get
this TBS is making a made-for-tv movie
about it I got a sneak peek at the
casting I want to share it with you
right now
first of all
first of all newest Republican candidate
Mike Huckabee is gonna be played by
Kevin Spacey I think that's very good
class former former Florida Governor Jeb
Bush will be played by a young Willard
Scott and looking for tonight yeah Texas
Governor Rick Perry will be played by
Josh Brolin's mug shot Texas senator Ted
Cruz will be played by Kevin from the
office just good Baskin that's amazing
casting yeah absolutely
all right South Carolina Senator Lindsey
Graham will once again be played by
Carol Brady we're all happy about that
Louisiana Governor Bobby Jindal will be
played by any Mad Magazine coverages
Democratic candidate Hillary Clinton
will be played by David Spade that
Kentucky Senator Rand Paul will be
played by late 90s here at Justin
Timberlake former hewlett-packard CEO
Carly Fiorina will be played by lime cat
senator from Vermont Bernie Sanders will
be played by a bowl of coleslaw this way
and finally New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie will be played by Mama June
from honey boo boo
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please